hi everyone this is Professor M science
and this is Professor M science first of
all we wanted to say thank you thank you
so much for being with us after all
these years um when we started making
the videos during the pandemic we really
didn't imagine that we were going to
last this long and that the videos were
going to be so useful for so many people
and that you're going to encourage us to
really keep going and that's been
amazing so thank you so much and thank
you also for hanging on with us
especially now that's taken a bit longer
than usual to publish new videos there's
a lot of work going on behind the scenes
and we can't always find the time to do
it but reading your messages really does
make a difference during these times and
the truth is that we really love making
Professor own videos and we have tons of
ideas of things that we would love to do
and in fact over the last few months
we've been working on some of them um
they're not already ready
but uh there is one thing that we did
want to share with you today we have
decided to start making maths videos and
the first series will focus on
differential equations of course
differential equations are essential in
physics but actually they're also very
very important Beyond physics in science
and engineering we hope you like them
we're going to use the same style we use
for the quantum mechanics videos and to
hear your feedback we're going to open a
discussion in the community tab to hear
your thoughts
and don't worry we are going to continue
making our quantum mechanics videos and
in fact right now we're working on a
series on spin angular momentum and I
think that's it thank you so much again
and see you
soon